three biden replacements okay wow wendy  in here uh we've been asking you  about ideas for who would be an  unconventional alternative to joe biden  if he doesn't run  in 2024 just having trouble  concentrating okay three ideas you guys  sent me number one ro khanna congressman  ro khanna friend of the show progressive  very good guy  number two katie porter uh congresswoman  katie porter super knowledgeable way  more knowledgeable than many of her  colleagues does an incredible job  questioning witnesses uh during house  hearings  option number three jamie raskin  incredibly well spoken  did so well during the trump impeachment  impeachment trial essentially  on the january 6 committee just very  good guy what do you think any of these  three  strike you as good possibilities for  2024 let me know in the comments